wir müssen nicht ins heim müssen nicht
ins bett von dem ruin
ich bin nicht die meisten folgen
aufgenommen von allen
ich werde wahrscheinlich auch schon so
machen dass ich täglich was hochladen
werde ich weiß natürlich nicht ob ich
das durchhalten kann oder so aber ich
sag jetzt einfach mal so weil ich habe
auf dieses projekt halten lange gewartet
und ja richtig wie er da von uns denkt
wie kann man sind bienen fangen wir
einfach kein bisschen mit dem wie hier
aus dass süchtig gegen biene ein
bienenstock da gibt es sogar was ehrlich
bienenwachs bienen hat er hasst du unten
bei die rabbiner eingegeben bienen rock
gibt es hast du unten bei der biene
eingegeben oder gab es sogar im internet
freigegeben und ja dann hast du ja doch
auf deutsch ja aber was wirklich so ein
bienen durch will ein haus die
begeisterung kann ich wie kann ich etwas
im krieg nieren relevanz ist das direkt
unter meinem haus einfach nur wissen es
gibt die kampagne was ist das denn
möchte ich mein grundstück eigentlich am
liebsten so flach haben
also ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was
ich mit diesem haus anfangen soll
ich brauche definitiv die menge an ihr
ist alles voll durchlöchert in meinem
grundstück ist überall drin trieb die
kommen nicht nur dass alba allgemein
hier sind überall höhlen und blauen
gefunden na ja da war ich auch schon das
im spot drin aber keine altem ich will
was ist mit den bienen wirst du lasten
gemacht
ich habe das ja nie gemacht fliegen die
bienen darum oder was nee da waren
bienenwaben habe mich richtig drauf
gemacht dann hatte ich dann also bienen
drin
die sich da wohl drin
gepaart haben oder durch die anderen
geparkt
ein eigenes häuschen rast auf seine in
der wildnis erwacht 60 gemacht
ich habe die gefunden das waren so
kleine blöcke halt muss ich vielleicht
ich glaube ich muss nicht diese
bienenschwarm stücke nicht einfach mal
finden sondern irgendwas anderes
irgendwo muss doch was sein
da ist auch so ein riesiger baum liebst
du mich ab und stehen dann direkt noch
in der stadt so ich muss jetzt guck ich
höre ich das ganze mache man darf ja die
begrenzung hier auch so ein bisschen
runter setzen ja ich denke schon ich bin
schon level 2 meine mutter gleich kurz
rein kommt weil die freundin weg und ich
hab nämlich buch meine schwester kein
problem kein problem hatte ich das hier
einfach raus und kämpft das dann aber
ihr das neue
also irgendwie bin ich sogar ich will
einfach imker seien mir ist alles
scheißegal ich will einfach immer sein
ich mag wo nicht
du kannst mit den bienen ja noch viel
mehr ehrlich in den tempel ja da musst
du an der seite sind die spawn drin wenn
du diese harz abbaus und bei manchen was
war da drin hängt eigentlich nur scheiße
eine horde ein bisschen stiefel
stiefelette stiefel also ich will jetzt
im k wert ich hab die schnauze wirklich
voll käfer die straße getreten wie heißt
das ding mit ketchup die hkb geschrieben
sowie sowie die sängerin so mit so einem
dollarzeichen und so ich habe einen
kescher mit voller mannschaft wetten
aber mit dem kescher wirklich bin fang
ist das wirklich richtig so wie kesha
geschrieben ich weiß nicht ob man damit
anfangen kann also durchaus auf jeden
fall ein kesha das hatte simon wollte
damit auch über den imker werden weil er
darf ja kein fleisch essen und so das
hatte dann minecraft auch angewendet und
blauen block sonderbericht dreht hat die
ganzen mourinho so krass ich glaube die
ebenerdigen vorüber ist
die chrysler allerdings das geil ich
liebe solche stellen warum ich will hier
nicht schon wieder eine hölle gehen aber
durch diesen ruin mode sind so viele
geile höhlen und capes entstanden liegt
20 jahre fiete wies
was meinst du denn was ist denn geld ist
da sind einfach keine andere spezielle
bauten das macht alles irgendwie wissen
mysteriöse dafür gerne auf
erkundungstour für nicht ja allgemein
weil doch relativ wenig kenntnis
ich finde das gibt dem ganzen einen
gewissen touch irgendwie habe ich das
gefühl gibt es keine schafe ich finde
ich die leute die sie provozieren
die provozieren nicht werden weil hier
sich überall bienenwaben ich habe noch
keine kesha was waren kesha hat gesagt
nein ich muss schlafen unter sich zwei
schafe die tätig ist ich bin schon die
hole die schafe am besten hier mit
weizen und dann fahren wir die unklar
sei was das weil es eigentlich auch in
machen wir uns jetzt einfach so ein
rummel und unter beiden häusern
ich würde eher sagen nicht wir können
das ja gerne mit diesem nebeneinander
wir können ja unsere häuser bauen und
vielleicht dann so eine kleine brücke
machen über den hauptweg überführt ja
stimmt genau machen
das finde ich ganz schnell raus weil ich
wollte auch schon tunnel zu den bauern
aber so einen richtigen langen und ganz
weit unten damit da kein anderer dann
irgendwie beim weg in die sich unter
button dann auf einmal fällt mir ein
dass letztlich ganz so cool ja keine
ahnung also eine brücke da nicht auch
noch gar nicht nicht mein hotline werde
ob ich da wirklich diese dieses vier
jahreszeiten feeling reinpacken werde
dass ich dann einfach da so ein bisschen
sand und da so ein bisschen schwanger
ist für jahreszeit für ihn also da ein
bisschen sand ein bisschen schnee
ich glaube die karibik habe ich glaube
einfach auf der einen seite rechts
direkt im haus und links ist dann
komplett fahren aber ihr dürftet dann
nicht an meine farm ran gehen oder wenn
die in einem grundstück ist 9
okay dann ist gut dass er genau wie
meine kisten sind ihr 2 spiels auch
nicht geschützt
und trotzdem geht ja keiner rein ich war
schon in meiner kiste aber ich hab den
nur aus holz benutzer erlaubt
als meine kesha einem kescher ich meine
die frau so erdogan macht den kescher
und jetzt rechtzeitig auf die biene oder
ware oder was hier irgendwie kam es
nicht ich kann mich natürlich catcher
gebieten ab und ich hab monströse
prinzessin
ja ja sag ich ja guckt antonstraße krone
und dann hat es auch alles auf deutsch
der papa wird klar wie wir hatten jetzt
ein kämpfer gemacht also einfach
unheimlich james und dingsda sticks und
volvo mann dafür
ich habe auch so viel wolle dass sich
die genug für ein bett gehen kann was
aber einfach unten kerscher eingehen
genau aber ohne das dollarzeichen
dann mache ich eben language wenn du
schatz findest rechte sehr verbunden
wenn du hier einen gelben geben könntest
wenn ich also du weißt ja wie man schaut
sagte die die süße dieser stein der so
richtig geld her geld nicht die einzige
farbe mir fehlt weil dann kann ich
meinen zauberstab laut hitachi
verbessern zwar noch nicht zum maximum
aber einfach mal meine kiste unter was
drin ist ich vertraue mir das nichts aus
ich bin jetzt doch irgendwo in der pampa
aber ich kann kann ich gar nicht gucken
ich hab noch 800 ml noch 700 meter bis
zur stadt wirklich weit weg gelaufen für
los
völlig sicher überall jetzt bienenwaben
und jetzt kommt papa dann mit seinem
kescher abbauen und schon wieder zwei
bescheide ich damit dieser phase einfach
ich kann die biene auch punk ab jetzt
zweier kammern und zwei zusammen
cathleen meier raus wer will ich dann in
japan und da wandelt man sich doch
überall schade dass ich keine knochen
wirklich 20 wölfe oder solch eine
volksarmee gemacht wenn mich mein
angreift importen sich ja immer die
wölfe dann soll ein tunnel nicht schon
die seine pyramide nicht richtig durch
vorstand werde ich da jetzt plündern
tätig
ja ich habe mich voll rein zu gehen weil
ich kein schwert hat und jetzt schon
wieder sind endermann auf meinem
grundstück oder dass der der mich in der
höhle von schon belästigt hat wir müssen
nicht wir müssen nicht mehr glatt von
dem ruin mode eine großtante mich jetzt
ab als mit zwei kloster aber ja ich bin
dir was mir wenn ich etwas finde da sind
nur zwei großen trainern in rimini toren
hat das ist für anrufe sms bekommen
hallo
nein nein nein sie dann nur das ist eine
konnte ich hab die ganze nicht
aufgenommen da habe ich weiß es nicht
falls ihr ein kleiner kater es tut mir
leid fenster runter gefallen gestorben
und ich habe jetzt erfahren wie man
berichtet bzw
neuruppin fängt nur weil ich hier
fertigt den klosterhof ist an allem
schuld
wir brauchen das auch beide wir wollen
doch beide internet pack oder daher
braucht ihr beide bloß so stimmt wie
viel los und brauchen eigentlich jeder 4
aber ich würde mehr holen weil so ein
jetpack hat schon mal kaputt also da
fahren zwei große blöcke und das erst
der erste block hat mir nur zwei oder
gebracht wir brauchen ja auch nur puder
oder läuft das brauchen wir
ich will die höhlen am liebsten einfach
zu bauen
das gute ist ich hab jetzt keiner mehr
das stark schwein also vorstellen kämpft
mit offenem mund im sub an und will
einfach was fressen der schweiz läuft
einfach eklig alte zeit
ich hab meine 35 level verloren die ich
hatte aber dass das ist echt ärgerlich
ich bin es level 463 fws ich hab das
immer zwischendurch einfach so ab gehabt
so auf einmal ein fps was ist da los
sekunde
es hat nicht die festplatten alten
rechner ist voll
gute alte rechner doch die ist voll
misst daran liegt dass muss ich kürzlich
festplatte ein stöpsel ganze nicht kurz
etwas löschen oder zum nächsten
das liegt an der aufnahme davor ich hab
da externe dabei ist es zu kurz ab 40
grad echt einer decke im zug und wird
zunehmen bei aufnehmen mit mir ich
brauche ganz ganz viel holz das ist so
ärgerlich gerade vorher rechner eine
reparatur ist fängt das projekt dann
aber na ja das tun was mit deinem
rechner passiert überhaupt
ja das war eigentlich heile lief auch
alles extrem gut leistungstechnisch
fantastisch aber manchmal ist er einfach
ausgegangen wenn ich meine ausgang nicht
so einfach der ist aber weg gewesen
ja ja das ist beim aber auch manchmal so
wenn ich einfach den ganzen tag rennen
anlass oder so und dann ein wenig davor
sitzt oder sondern auch wenn man an dass
der so auf anfrage nicht sehr hell dann
wünschten maximilian und dann ist das
ist das so manchmal auch wenn ich gar
nichts machen geht aber geht aber nichts
wtf ist wieder die festplatte nicht an
dem modell tag bei familie kehrt
ich werde jetzt einmal die ganzen hierzu
bonn dpa schneller kommt einfach mal ein
stück weg hier ja die ganze zeit gleich
durch die ganze zeit sind ja echt prima
dass mit mir richtig auf creepers bonn
hatte erhält endlich eine 500 gb soll
reichen
ich finde er der schon gesagt dass jeder
in werne hin baut oder so meine den ja
was was bringt das
keine ahnung richtig also ich werde
stark dafür dass wir so ein bürger meist
sondern rates sollte auch mit kleinen
rathaus knast ariane alles in ein dass
wir da auch so dass schilder aufhängen
können was
man so ein verbesserungen hat für alles
komplette zusammenleben mit weiterer
bevor es doch mal so da bin ich wieder
festplatte voll extern geschafft es ist
ja über alles gespottet also dass sie
nicht gestorben bin nein ich weiß was
ich vorhin gesagt habe es wäre cool wenn
irgendwie wenn die anderen das die
gucken oder dann könnte die anderen
unterschreiben dass sie davon halten
dass wir ein haus bauen wo wir auch so
wünsch aufhängen irgendwie zum beispiel
ja das was man sich also wünscht zum
beispiel ein trackpad in heft
doppelpunkt ich wäre dafür wenn man über
50 level hatte man steht dass man sich
der bezirk und kann ich jetzt eine blöde
sache aber sollte einfach nur mal kurz
ein beispiel ich wünsche mir kuchen
das ist natürlich auch eine wichtige
sache der dfl
hey komm ich pass in den rücken
naja auf einen tisch geschlagen die
gleiche stelle und ich mir wieder
eingefallen wto normal hill auf 91 weg
dafür musste ich mal ganz kurzen speed
shop machen
discover vor mir und mainz aus irgendwie
weg was ich bin was zum teil folgen die
ich gerade aufgenommen sind einfach
sowas von viele fans bisher passiert das
ist unglaublich was zum team gehört das
ist echt krank auch wenn man die map
ganz groß vor mir
die kriegt die map den weg auf x-bow
unterdessen kripo vor mir was ich bin
gerade in der stadt wo den letzten todes
punkt leck mich am arsch alter ich sage
es noch mit den ganzen fans meine mobil
aufnahme wurde wieder gestoppt ich mach
mal kurz das alter
das kann nicht sein meint todes punkt
wurde jetzt nicht gespeichert ich weiß
nicht wo ich hin laufen soll